[Music]
in never enough news Oh submitted by
water toes what is that I think it's the
froggy things like a water world when
they got the web's yeah uh water toes I
just fill in the blanks in my head okay
it made it less weird I don't like
anything else when you say it all that
water toes water toes like whatever it
may be is what what are those what are
those
Oh hmm water toes was it water toes
water table a bar owner went out of his
way for a patron and she still only gave
him a four star overview damn y'all
people on Yelp be harsh Dobrin
I'm telling you you guys are [ __ ] me
what happened here hmm so this pub owner
in Scotland Scotland he posted up on
Twitter he said so the pit oh my gosh
accent go I can't you have to do it you
have to keep it accurate
come on groundskeeper Willie comes from
my heart don't even think about it your
inner strength don't use your brain hang
on I looked after your dog all night
merlot too cold apparently yeah so wait
they came into the bar with their doggie
they left the bar without the doggie
without the dog oh my you slept over at
the pub to take care of the dog and then
and so yeah and then so here sweetie
again this girl she only gave us four
stars
[Music]
what did the four star say I'm not sure
I don't have that review and plus just
to point it out there I don't know how
true that for stress for four star
remark is because it could just be like
a joke like oh and she only gave us four
story so I'm not sure how true that it
oh right it's just that that's what he
said so that's what me that's our truth
yes so he posted with the caption when
your wife wants to know why you didn't
come home last night and you have to
produce evidence to support your
implausible claim that one of your
punter one of the punters forgot to take
their dog with them both now happily
reunited with our with our owners both
both yet look husband with his wife and
the dog with though he [ __ ] somebody
overnight with their dog he bought the
dog yes this is the tweet that says the
Forester forgot old uh review so the
[ __ ] up woman so she came back and
picked up her dog that I say and still
only gave it four stars maybe the dog
lost some weight yeah then so a lot of
people were saying well why didn't you
just take the dog to your house and then
he said that is because he has cats and
the daughter wouldn't have let his
daughter wouldn't have let the dog leave
again she just took it to the pound
that's the doggie hotel I won't just
open the door and let it out oh you know
dogs know how to get don't care they not
even know some of them are dumb oh okay
it's know how to get home some are
really dumb one of them is really
different one of our dogs is really dumb
but she's the most lovable not I can't
say most she has the brain of a
butterfly no where the [ __ ] cuz you know
monarch butterflies pigeon she has the
brain of a pinecone that's it yes
she's so cute yes you don't know what
are the [ __ ] she's at yeah she doesn't
know Apple from Sky oh no to talk I know
what David said cuz he said that Yelp
reviewers are the worst that's true I
bet you this was a person anybody that
has a profile picture on Yelp and has
done 500 reviews like not a good person
yeah not a good person
like verified Yelp user and verified
loser yeah pretty much why are you doing
that [ __ ] it's like like my in my spare
time I like to tell people how to run
their business that's exactly what it is
what it is and I think like like I said
Yelp does help Yelp does help yep oh
that's me their slogan yeah Yelp does
help and I do appreciate you know people
who lead positive comments negative
comments are good for criticism too but
you should bring it up with the owner
first before you decide to write this
crazy bad thing about them you know like
give them a chance at least first you
know say hey you're messing up on me but
instead what they'll feel this is what
they did but you didn't talk to them
about it so they didn't even get a
chance to give you your money back give
you some new food or just posting it on
Yelp they're already so
passive-aggressive that of course
they're not gonna go I appreciate you
but I wish some people would understand
that you're you know they're hurting
people's lives yeah I think some people
will also do it on Yelp because they
don't feel like it's gonna go to the
higher-ups to not to defend the Yelpers
but that's kind of what I feel like I
only do one star or five stars if a
restaurant blows me away like oh this is
a [ __ ] awesome place or it's my
friend's place I put five stars but if
they really offend me there's only two
times when I did it one time is we got
scammed it was a you know like those
crawfish places and I was I came in with
a scale because not to check their [ __ ]
but that's because I was on a diet and I
had to do that did you know it's like a
small little digital scale oh okay I
didn't I was like what the [ __ ] I was
supposed to buy a half a pound of crab
like this is only like a quarter pound
Wow with the shell yeah so then I called
them out on it and then they're like
your scales broke in and I'm like oh
you're [ __ ] caught this is a this is
a bad place so I have to [ __ ] report
that and then I was like damn those are
the only times when I would do it is if
it's fraudulent bad business practice or
really [ __ ] me cuz I used to what I
when Yelp first started like I just like
you know writing a few things here and
there and everybody that I gave like
either like a three or whatever I just
deleted it cuz it's just it's just a
business you know
so it's either one four or five that's
all you get two or three don't exist you
either [ __ ] me good
that's it yeah two or three is like
you're thinking about it way too hard
it's like I want to be mean but not that
like what did you have a checklist they
only pass like seven at it I feel like
if you're gonna give it three just leave
it alone
it's just an okay business that's all
you had to do you know very logical yeah
especially it saves my life though when
I travel to places uh I'm just I don't
even know that [ __ ] works it does when
we were in France uh I got some Japanese
food info Ransa I got food on we went
twice it was so damn good
Asian spot infrared so for some odd
reason we found it was like one of the
fans were like you should try this out
and it was like one of the best places
so I checked on Yelp and had like four
and a half stars yeah and I was like
what I went to a lot of four and half
stars in France and it was terrible
really
American yeah it'd be the best here
you're not late even in the Bay Area
this like Japan was it was useless why
it was [ __ ] useless I had no idea
they think Europe - they had their own
version of Yelp where it's just
specifically for restaurants yeah so I
didn't know that at the time works for
LA or every other big American city yeah
it's weird though because sometimes so
there's like this Japanese restaurant I
went out to in Alhambra right it was
like a sushi joint I had like four stars
like 800 views it was because the
portions are huge and so they're like oh
it's so good I went that it was it was
like fish tank sushi or something no I
can't it's the one it's really close to
the the Tokyo table it's like if you go
to Tokyo tables right the corner I'm
talking about another one by the dog
groomer oh well that's interesting you
know anytime I see a Chinese restaurant
with more than four stars I question it
like I'm like you're not authentic I
expect it to be three and a half that's
how you know it's good it's gotta have
that [ __ ] yellow color and then
just look at the picture because usually
the bad reviews is because like customer
service yeah there's just different
culturally right so when it comes with
good food yeah but if the customer
service is too good I know it's [ __ ]
PF Changs I'm not going there yeah mmm
does it overcompensating for yeah I'm
like I'm not going there their foods
probably horrible hmm yeah I want my
service to be really bad at Asian
restaurants yeah I want to come in and I
want you to look at me like you want me
out yep it tastes like a little bit
better now I want you to ask me what I'm
doing here lamb all the plates
yeah you better put a [ __ ] thumb in
my water cup yeah but you sit down in
your waitress is like are you lost
I want to like get their attention and
they just look at me and look like what
you guys because I live there yep put
your thumb just like that I want them to
take my order and while they're riding
it out have a conversation with her
friend and walk away they give you the
menu with 400 options and then they ask
are you ready to order in your life oh I
want them to bring me my food and to
never come back like I have to call the
desk to get them to bring me the check
like that's what I want you're inside
the restaurant I still kinda trust
reviews actually though because just
recently I saw that place called howl
and raised in LA it has like 4.7 stars
right but everybody keeps saying there's
a line that's like an hour and a half to
three hours there's no way that I'm
gonna give you five stars if I just
waited for three hours I don't care like
there's not efficient right yeah yeah
absolutely not like I think in Happy
Endings at the end or like three coupons
I'm gonna do it the food though that's
stressful
did you end up eating the food no I just
read the reviews and I wanted it was
great yeah I know but I'm just like how
when y'all waited for three hours
I'm right there with you because I live
like a couple blocks away but I don't go
because of that reason yeah I don't go
cuz it's like I can't wait for two hours
it's crazy polymerase is delicious I'm
not gonna wait that long for it w yeah
there's a lot of other like great fried
chicken joints that taste in my personal
opinion just as [ __ ] good
you know just how it has like Gus's is
Gus's there's just one dude that he just
pops up in this like truck I don't know
where the [ __ ] he's a toe I figure out
his name but you have to fight it but
he'll let everybody know on his Twitter
where he's at
well I think that does chicken fried
[ __ ] it was way better than holidays
we're gonna find that like how sick is
that that somebody's just like Moberly
tweeting like hey my restaurants here
today like it would be they would have
their Twitter going and then they would
tell people like we're gonna be here in
here and then the line would just
another thing my business would lies if
I did that cuz I'd be so judgmental I
Drive up and be like y'all [ __ ]
losers dude me throughout the whole your
do you have kids or something what are
you doing here you do yeah and then I
just judged them and I Drive away
because I'm like I only want to serve
successful people there's a food good
though probably you know what fried
chicken is one of those foods that it is
never good at home compared to buying
somewhere else it's the deep fries the
deep frying that the [ __ ] clean up
the mess the work I never ever will ever
cook fried chicken ever again because it
just doesn't taste like Church's Chicken
tastes way better than the [ __ ] that I
make yeah that's true it's something
about the battery's not good you need
the peanut oil too
yeah oh yeah yeah you can't use regular
vegetable oil well that makes it takes a
lot different like chick-fil-a they use
peanut oil
that's my sodium good old man
chick-fil-a good that's the only way I
would eat breast
[Music]
[Music]